i got my merch on do you have your merch
on we're about to watch the rocky movies
talk about some of the health effects
that my man rocco has faced let's get
into it
hey yo rocco
i never understood why boxers did this
back in the day or frankly any athletes
i can't help but think about salmonella
falling into his cup right now because i
bet those are not pasteurized in shell
eggs he doesn't look like he was fancy
enough to be buying those and salmonella
you can go many eggs without getting it
i think the statistic is 1 in 20 000
eggs contains salmonella but that one
time you get it you're gonna wish you
did it also i believe that there's a
fact out there eating raw eggs
decreases your ability to absorb biotin
which is good for hair skin and nails
well we deserve it we've been getting
away with murder for the last couple of
weeks how high today could possibly be
why are you spilling it on your shirt
guys
this is so unnecessary not only is he
punching raw meat that should be used
for human eating consumption but he's
also punching ribs hurting his knuckles
because he doesn't have boxing gloves on
as any boxer would know an injury to
your knuckles is an injury to your
boxing career potentially
you're breaking the ribs
also he's throwing punches in kind of
like a weird form i don't know what that
is he's not like throwing a straight
shot he's not throwing a hook he's kind
of like doing some kind of in-between
overhand thing
those wraps smell like bath
with the same beanie on except mine's
merch link down below to sign up for the
new merch release coming soon you lay
off that pet shop game
women weaken legs
the scientific accuracy of that
statement just has never been proven to
be true whether you look at hormone
levels you look at performance it just
there's no pattern that has emerged
there and i'll tell you why because i
don't think it's women i don't think
it's sex i think it's the act of getting
boozed up stressed out
staying up late that's what weakens the
legs but it's not the women or the sex
that's causing it i call misinformation
on that one
get him on the speed bag
yeah rocco
that's actually really hard there's an
element of plyometrics there shoulder
strengthening core strengthening a lot
of stuff is happening this is really
impressive
core training for boxing is so important
because not only are you needing the
ability to absorb hits but you also need
the ability to turn your body that's how
you develop strength in boxing
[Music]
can someone get this guy a proper
punching bag the cows need a break
[Music]
that kind of exercise on the stairs is
obviously the iconic rocky moment and
while i think stairs are a great
exercise i think it trains your lower
body extremely well your cardiovascular
system extremely well i prefer doing
like the aero bike to that because
you're getting an upper and lower body
workout and a hit workout at the same
time
[Applause]
nasal fractures are very common injury
especially in boxing 40 to 50 percent of
facial fractures happen in the nose but
two things can happen you can form a
septal hematoma which is blood pooling
in an area causing immense pressure
problems and it actually needs to be
drained and then the second thing that
could happen is you could have a
fracture of your cribiform plate where
you actually start leaking cerebral
spinal fluid also known as csf
right body shots are brutal because not
only do you have the potential for
breaking someone's ribs which obviously
is extremely painful hurts your ability
to rotate hurts your ability to breathe
but also because your liver is there and
a shot to the liver with its unique
position within the body and its unique
relationship with the nervous system and
the circulatory system a shot to the
liver will bring you down i can't see
nothing gotta open my eye
come here i don't wanna do it
[Applause]
this is such a terrible scene okay so we
no longer do this what's happening here
is he has a hematoma over his eye
swelling blood pooling and essentially
he's saying cut it open so the fluid can
leak out and i can actually open my eye
and see that was done incredibly not
safe he didn't even disinfect the area
first that's going to be a problem
nowadays this is not legal cut men are
not actually cutting you they're
actually stopping your cuts from
bleeding and gauging on whether or not
the cut is dangerous to the person's
life or vital organs come on
go on and get him get him get him get
him come on what's the matter with you
but there's better
ways to do
training than torturing a poor chicken
running around there's just there's
exercises you can do where you don't
need to chase a chicken my husband and i
thank you for coming to our training
quarter today well hello my fellow
russian immigrant
i'm glad to face you if there have been
rumors of blood doping and widespread
distribution of anabolic steroids in the
soviet union has drago partaken in any
such experiments no anabolic steroids
blood doping it is a real thing in
professional sports even though there
are steps put in place to prevent it
like drug testing russia also had a huge
scandal with anabolic steroids i highly
recommend there's a documentary on
netflix called icarus definitely check
that out because it just shows you how
dirty and nasty all of these games are
behind the scenes
[Music]
drago averages
and 1850 pounds
so the results quite obvious
that he's strong what does the
technology have to do with it this guy
didn't describe anything it looks like
he created those arcade things that you
see on tick tock videos of people
failing and hitting the top of it and
breaking their hands
take so much money
yeah the reason the referee has to come
in and step in or the corner has to
throw in the towel is because the
fighter no longer can make decisions for
themselves if you take too many punches
to the head it's very easy to find
yourself in that position so if you see
a fighter that's just getting hit
repeatedly repeatedly not being able to
throw back not being able to show that
he's doing any kind of movement or
action that puts his life in jeopardy
that's where he gets shut down and
stopped
what's interesting is that a lot of the
deadly blows and most damaging blows in
boxing come over a period of time
multiple blows over over over again not
like that one strong knockout that
actually ends up knocking you down and
there's a lot of problems when it when
you start having bleeding in the brain
because the skull is an enclosed
environment there's nowhere for that
blood to go so if the person starts
bleeding a they're not getting blood
flow to the actual part of their brain
that's necessary but it also starts
building up pressure putting more
pressure on the brain essentially
shutting parts of the brain down if your
brain stem shuts down the part that's
responsible for respiratory rate or
cardiac rate that shuts down that's when
you die if he dies
he does
rocco wear the chest compressions
you don't know why he's dying what if
he's bleeding internally he needs some
chest compressions check his pulse rocco
i guess that guy is riding but it's not
clear what that was and earlier it was
mentioned blood doping blood doping is
basically either getting transfusions of
blood either from yourself or from
someone else or they give themselves a
chemical known as epo erythropoietin
which is actually a chemical made by
your kidneys that increase the
production of red blood cells thereby
increasing your oxygen carrying ability
russians cut
it's kind of a weird way to say it
that last punch was so fake it was bad
he just went like this and nothing even
happened and there was the sound effect
[Applause]
boxing actually has this 10 count right
there's a person who stands outside the
ring and actually starts the count and
holds the count also once a fighter is
up it doesn't necessarily mean they're
ready to fight if the referee deems that
the fighter is not able to protect
themselves like if the referees like
move left move right hold up your arms
in front of you if you're unable to do
that that means you're unable to protect
yourself the fight is still over
[Music]
what's wrong
i can't
i can't stop my hands from shaking
i mean maybe it's a good time to go to
the hospital i'm just tired
i just want to go home okay at this
point there should be a
ring physician or ringside physician
coming in doing a neurocheck making sure
that neurologically he's intact he's
fine he's stable and i don't feel like
that's happening here recently the
american medical association recommended
that boxing be banned yeah do you agree
with the doctor is boxing a dangerous
sport that is unhealthy for your brain
yes is there a way
to practice boxing practice boxing not
actually
fight and be healthy yes in fact there's
a lot of healthy benefits to boxing when
you're calculating someone's risk in
their life you're not just looking at
one activity there's a lot of variables
those who step inside the ring and risk
getting hit in the face and cause cte to
their brain they're taking a risk i
think it's their choice i think a lot of
people make that choice you know
absolutely i i think the doctor should
never fight you know did he just say
that i shouldn't fight rocco i'm sorry
buddy but i gotta do it because of the
continuous violent blows to the head
you've developed a condition particular
to boxes called cavum septum folliculum
which is a hole in the membrane
separating the ventricles the brain
surface neurons in this area have also
been traumatized i don't even know what
the heck they're looking at here it says
physical there's some kind of
beautiful lines there's different cuts
that we're looking at here maybe a
functional mri like an early one the
reality is the condition they're talking
about is one that has been associated
not proven to have happened with contact
sport athletes fighters football players
etc it's been associated with cte
chronic traumatic encephalopathy we have
tied the condition to worse mood
outcomes worse scores but it's also
something that can happen during
development and be an incidental finding
and sort of like a normal variant on
imaging so there's still a lot of
questions to be answered what causes
this exactly how does it happen because
there's only theories out there so far
and what are the implications if it does
happen if you've never had it before and
in fact i know in the future uh rocky
movies he goes back to fighting so
clearly this wasn't a reason for him to
retire i think i wanna like do something
like what
fight
[Music]
i don't know that you need to squat 10
plates in order to be a box
and he loves his raw eggs my man just
gets some whey protein powder it's
ridiculous
he's literally asking to tear his bicep
by doing that
oh my god he's punching the cows again
just god
the effects got better but not much
better
and
[Applause]
another fighter's bone with a bad angle
is very problematic elbow you go to hit
a body shot the elbow hits you in the
thumb and the wrist could potentially
break your hand hitting someone in the
hip bad angle can turn the wrist sprain
it break it another one is on the skull
you go to punch a fighter they tilt
their skull down it flexes your wrists
like this over flexes it potentially
sprains tears breaks bone here
how's the hand my ass bro how's the hand
my hands broke that's it throw in the
fight there's no need to continue
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what did you say to the kid
it ain't about how hard you hit
it's about how hard you can get hit
and keep moving forward uh that's not
exactly true boxing is the sport of
hitting and not getting hit
rocco is not the only boxer in the house
this doctor is a boxer too click here to
check that out as always stay happy and
healthy click here check it out
[Music]
well you know who can box in an office
chair huh